tre is with us in Georgia what do you
think before tre um well first I'm
thankful for my health and I'm fortunate
enough to have a lot of our family here
to be able to celebrate with them so
that the most of thankful for all the
active military members that are not
able to be with their parents and
fighting for our freedom so amen
cool how can I help today ah so I had a
question about my vehicle I'm trying to
figure out what you thought I should do
all on baby step number two I just
stayed off my first credit card good and
my my car is the last thing in my debt
snowball unfortunately because of a lot
of stupid decisions I made prior I'm
stuck with a high payments about ten
thousand dollars in negative equity and
I'm trying to figure out if I should
just start paying down the negative
equity as quickly as possible or just
keep going to debt snowball as I usually
would okay what do you owe on the car
total just about thirty thousand and
change for about thirty thousand five
hundred outside so you think it's worth
around twenty around twenty Yahoo book
Kelley Blue Book okay Kelly Blue Book is
a private sale it's about twenty
thousand and some change perfect okay
and um and so you wrote negative equity
into that deal probably from your last
meal right right I bought a car I had a
four-runner that I had no payment on
obviously I should accept but I bought
it I bought a jeep and it turned out to
be a lemon it was out of warranty and I
had to put a new engine in it so that
obviously got put on credit cards
because I didn't have the money
trickle effect to there so my mechanic
who's very trusted advisor close family
friend of ours said you need to get rid
of this car it's gonna keep giving you
issues so I did it all I need to do is
take it in trade my point is that you
rolled a negative equity from the last
car into this car and drop $10,000 in
value by itself correct now that's what
I thought okay so what's your household
income my base salary is fifty three
grow
but then I also have a side hustle where
I make about $800 a month so what's your
household income that make it about
sixty-five thousand a year are you
married right and no I'm single I'm that
kid okay so you got 65 thousand dollars
a year you have a thirty thousand dollar
car note on a $20,000 car okay couple of
rules a couple of rules of thumb that I
use rule of thumb number one is even if
they're all paid for don't own vehicles
things with motors and wheels all added
together including your freaking
lawnmower all of it added together
should not be more than half your annual
income because things with motors and
wheels go down in value rapidly okay as
you have discovered now the second rule
of thumb I use is can you be debt-free
in two years other than your home and
keep this car so you have thirty
thousand dollars owed on the car what
other debts do you have what's the total
of your debt right now as I said it's
about one hundred and eleven thousand
five hundred and twenty five dollars
okay you need to sell the car because
the car is twenty thousand dollars of
your debt on a hundred eleven and you
make sixty five thousand dollars a year
you need to be driving a two thousand
dollar car while you clean this mess up
right and that means you're gonna have
to borrow the difference that ten
thousand dollars who is the loan with on
the thirty uh Toyota finance okay
they're gonna be no help at all so
you're going to talk to your local
credit union your small town bank
somebody that you can actually sit in
front of and explain to them this
situation is your credit trashed yeah
pretty much
okay it's gonna make this very difficult
but as soon as you can get this car sold
by paying by borrowing ten thousand
dollars and getting rid of this payment
and having a payment on ten thousand
dollars instead of a payment on thirty
thousand dollars that's going to help
you towards being debt-free inside of
two years
the car itself does not violate the half
of your annual income because $20,000
value is less than half the vow less
than half of 65,000 but it is a big
chunk of your debt it is a big mess it
is a high interest rate and they have
taken you to town brother and you're
gonna have to cut them loose so I would
go borrow the ten thousand and I would
get the car sold if there's any way that
you can do that reasonably if you can't
then you're gonna pay payments on it for
a while while you work your debt
snowball until you can get to it and
when you can get the payment I mean when
you can get the negative equity reduced
then you can sell it if you can't borrow
the difference you probably can borrow
the difference it's probably going to
take some work but getting out of debt
takes work and cleaning up past sins
that we all have takes work it's a hard
thing to go back and you know clean up a
mess that you have made and that's what
you've done here so yeah this is a I'm
sorry man you are really in a pickle but
you really going to have to work to get
out of it and otherwise it's going to
you know you're just going to wallow in
this mess forever and we certainly don't
want that